welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss here with
mt mastertainment to talk about episode
five of the falcon the winner soldier
what an episode right nt yes oh man
especially at the beginning that
beginning fight was
amazing outstanding i am probably gonna
rewatch it several times
yes uh there's so much in this episode
we're going to take some questions we're
uh we got some great questions from our
listeners on stereo and we're just going
to go
always listen but before we begin this
video is brought to you by squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
to run your business
let's start with this question uh what
was in that box
that uh bucky gave sam presumably from
the wakandans we talked about
this a bit in inside marvel what do we
presumably there's going to be some kind
of new
suit some kind of new armored suit new
wings for sam built by
wakandan so it's probably made of
vibranium but what do we think the
visual of this is going to be what do we
think the functionality is going to be
i mean personally i think i'm more
leaning towards the
the winged captain america suit because
cap
sam wilson does not have powers in in
you know
in the mcu so he's gonna have to have
some type of advantage and
i believe in the comics he he also does
have the wings on his captain america
suit
so i i think we're going to see um
just a vibranium wings um and just a
more
black white uh red white and blue suit
um just like like we see in the comics
we're just gonna get
we're gonna see him captain america
proper maybe that suit will
be designed to have a slot for the
shield
so it will kind of re-appropriate the
visual of the shield
into the suit somehow that would be
really cool
the goofy version of this is that star
spells is the a
of like falcon or something
that'd be dumb as hell but uh but yeah
if it somehow
incorporates the design of the shield to
be part of a new look that's just
uniquely for
falcon uh and we know that we have to
assume that shield is made of vibranium
or something like that
um maybe even though wakandans are
experimenting with like
vibranium alloys and they came up with a
proto-adamantium
so that shield is or that whole suit is
gonna be made of proto-adamantium to
match
this new shield that they've been
fumbling around uh
and that that way sam doesn't have to
carry it the same way you can just kind
of like
latch it to the back of his shield or
the back of his hands
to kind of protect him in some ways and
then he can use it and weaponize it in
other ways
that would be sick that would be like
are you sure you're not working you
didn't work with sherry on this
are you sure you didn't you didn't do
that because it sounds like you have
some insider information eric
i wish i wish i worked in the labs of
wakanda
what a great job that would be right
yeah let's take i i have these questions
i have one from liz reese right now
let's i'm gonna try to play it
what do you guys think about john walker
getting a maybe
uh adamantium or a proto-adamantium
shield from madame hydra
after his five-minute diy craft shield
breaks into pieces
so uh all right so we all heard that
from liz great question liz i i
think it is a interesting question
for that shield to be made of
proto-adamantium i don't know if john
walker himself
has the welding skills to handle
something that's supposed to be one of
the
the sturdiest metals of the world
yeah it seems like you know with with
ultron in age of ultron there he has to
use a lot of heat to really
um mess with uh vibranium stuff so like
for him to just have the
the the equipment in his garage or
whatever the hell he's at
i don't think so so i i i don't suspect
it to be any sort of real
like vibranium or any crazy alloy
uh myself but who knows we don't know
how connected
this uh contessa is so yeah i am
eager eager eager to get uh uh
adamantium in the universe so if
anybody's new tech
if it has some bit of adamantium in it
please get that
in this final episode oh my god uh let's
take another question this is from chris
cestaro
so how do we feel now knowing that sam
even said to bucky
within the show steve's gone
is he really gone is he dead or is he
just saying
he's gone like out of our lives
oh yeah i i
right yeah i honestly feel like they're
using the word
gone for a reason because like i feel
like at this point episode five like we
would have gotten the word died or like
you know
the funeral or some mention of him being
dead dead
but the word gone is keeps being used
and so i feel like he's not
dead he's around but he's just not
available
um i just thought it was interesting
that they said what steve thought
doesn't matter
it's kind of like a pretty strong way
for the show to say
don't worry about what captain america's
steve rogers intentions were on stuff
like don't worry about what the avengers
of the past
thought was right and wrong like we're
in a new era now we make the decisions
we're the ones fighting this fight
um
i don't know if that means the same
thing
if anything they have more worries not
nowhere
it's true never but just like more so
about like forgetting the past i mean
just like it's
yes yeah for sure we should feel hakuna
matata
exactly yes yes yes um but like
yeah i want old cap to be on a moon base
i want him to be on the moon put put
chris evans in a fishbowl helmet
floating around with the inhumans on the
moon
please oh my god hopefully nothing in
humans let's let's keep that far away
the influence could be good not the
marvel tv in humans yes
i mean i deserve a good human story i
mean scott bucks and humans specifically
let's not do that ever again but like in
humans i i'm a huge proponent of being
humans in the mcu
karnak is my baby is my favorite marvel
superhero like period like that's not
even exaggeration
so i really do want the inhumans that's
just yeah excited but i
to what you were saying mt i don't think
gold cap is dead um
because they would have just said dead i
think either the people working on the
show
are not told by kevin feige what their
plans are for old cap and they're like
just say he's gone
like he tells us yeah we we won't go
into it more than that
but i don't think they want to commit to
him being dead yet because they might
have other stories they want to tell
with them and again thanks to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
want to start a website for your
business maybe you run a stark
industries but with any
because you're based in stark florida
and you've noticed a big demand for
merch with your logo on it well present
your completely legal copyright adjacent
hats and tease using squarespace's
professional portfolio designs
display projects and customizable
galleries you can auto post your content
to twitter facebook or tumblr
they have built-in mobile websites and a
really slick mailing list feature to
stay in touch with your customers
squarespace will even sell you a url
just head to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com
new rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain that's
squarespace.com
new rockstars for 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain
bobby's got a question here on stereo we
saw bucky's arm kind of glitch out but
we never got anything more of that
and he didn't really use it on the boat
except to rip that one end piece off do
you think his arm is broken
and he's kind of i'm done with the
winter soldier i'm done with having a
metal arm but he still has a super
soldier serum so i don't really get it
yeah there was an interesting moment
where his arm glitched out for a second
i was
worried uh yeah and by even by the end
of that fight he seemed to be using his
arm again
right yeah i i honestly think that
the arm may not be in the best shape i
think that it could be like
glitchy-ish and like that could factor
in in
the last episode where like he tries to
do something but then it's like oh no
like it got damaged in the fight with
john walker
and like he's gonna get a eventually a
new arm i don't think he ends this
series
um with the wakandan arm that he got oh
yeah
oh no like like i said uh the other day
like it's all about action figures man
it's all
about making action figures that man's
going to have a different arm
he's going to be rotating arms for as
long as he's in the mcu honestly
that's an arm i'm going to bring color
um
yeah i think the presumption of uh
bucky's detainment of zemo with the door
melange is that bucky had been hanging
out with the wakandans and that whatever
fixes whatever sprucy enough they need
to do to that arm they would have done
then
off screen um that was just mine that is
true
that is true that is very did not glitch
i think they just needed a moment of
drama
towards the end of that fight to be like
oh and they cut back to bucky kind of
like randy in a christmas story he's
still laying on the ground
like oh [ __ ] he's still now to back up
okay so
he got another move but
yeah bucky skips his turn
bucky's still asleep
all right next question yeah emerson's
got a question here
would you rather see torres just use the
mechanical type wings
or do you want to see him mutated and
like
have the bird powers and everything
well emerson i can't speak for mt i want
to see some freaky body horror
yeah if it's on earth or like use
technology to be the version of yours so
i'm more
i'm thinking that mc is just going to be
like use technology but i wanna what do
you wanna empty i want
freaky i mean like you know like with
episode one when we first got introduced
to torres i assume that that's what they
were gonna do that they were gonna
augment torres and they use we're gonna
get some freaky bird [ __ ]
have a bird man um but
um i think that they're you know with
this new episode with sam saying keep
the wings
tories gonna be like yes now i can be a
nerd and make my own suit
um so we're definitely gonna get a more
metal like more technology-based suit
but i would
personally like to see um a mutated
torres but i don't think we're gonna get
that um
plus it costs more money to mutate
somebody with cgi
so i think they're just gonna be like
put on the suit kid and it's
cheaper this way and it's more realistic
so it's fine
um but that's just my interpretation of
that
i think it's a good interpretation uh
let's take another question here
what the falcon is up
with sharon and making it seem like
she sent batshock to kill sam the first
time and now doing it again
yeah what is sharon carter doing like
what is
what is her plan who is she really
working for i mean
there's everyone has like a different
theory with their own set of evidence
that is conclusive
uh smoking gun whether it's she is
working for the cia she's working for
some other government agencies she's
secretly the power broker she is a
scroll
you know but ultimately i think she's
just working for some kind of criminal
agency that is outside the law if she's
in madrid
i personally don't think she's actually
working for a government thing trying to
destabilize that
uh that criminal organization just
because i don't see what interests they
would have in
sending in bad truck to work with the
the flag smashers even if it was to
bring down the flag smashers from the
inside there's other ways to do that
and why even let them get so close to
the grc to bring down
and to throw smoke bombs in that council
room
you would think you would just beat them
up there in central park and then take
them in
you know yeah uh
yeah i think she is uh she's working for
some criminal
organization she is selfishly trying to
move up in that organization that she
has been doing
this time in madrid um and i think
we won't know until we know who or what
the power broker is
this is true um like ditto from eric you
know it's just too early to know
what's going on but like if i were to
take a stab at it
i think that she's working on behalf of
some type of organization like it's some
type of
something like um um i mean
specifically a governmental organization
um
i just don't know to in what capacity
whether it's united states whether it's
some other government it's just
she i just i don't think that things are
what they seem
i think that we're we're sort of being
set up to believe that sharon is you
know
playing like an evil person but it just
doesn't line up with
the character that um marvel has set her
up to be so far
so i don't know i agree with you there
we agree with you
there's been a lot of jumping around
with her character logically and just a
lot of questions
in every episode we just have more
questions about who we're going to yeah
rather than
closing doors of the possibilities um
but maybe that's by design
that's it for this episode of our inside
marvel q and a
hey a reminder that not only can you get
our anarchy assembled shirt at
nurseriesmerch.com
have an opportunity to write in a custom
shout out for inside marvel episodes
you uh can also get your hands on a new
zemo inspired shirt that looks amazing
yes
because we're always yeah get this shirt
get your hands on the shirt
uh again that is at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow mt at
mastertainment follow me at eavos follow
the new rockstar subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you for
watching and we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
you